Auf Motivsuche im ewigen Eis
der Arktisfotograf Norbert Rosing
nimmt für spektakuläre Bilder
Minustemperaturen von bis zu
38 Grad Celsius in Kauf.
Auf solche Szenen wie in der
kanadischen Provinz Manitoba
wartet er manchmal mehrere Wochen.
Seine besten Bilder sind jetzt in
dem Buch "Up Here" erschienen:
die Schönheit des hohen Nordens
festgehalten in gestochen scharfen Bildern.
Seit dreißig Jahren reist der Naturfotograf
in den Nordpolarkreis.
In seinem Haus in der Nähe von München
erinnert sich Rosing an
außergewöhnliche Begegnungen
– etwa mit einer Eisbärenfamilie.
Sie schlief, sie ruhte da mit ihren Jungen.
Und dann fing sie plötzlich mit
denen an zu spielen,
und dann ist die Temperatur
innerhalb von einer Stunde
von minus dreißig auf minus acht gestiegen
und plötzlich fing es an zu regnen.
Und dann merkten wir plötzlich, wie
die Bärin anfing,
ihre Jungen trocken zu lecken,
weil die wurden ja alle nass und
das ist ja sehr gefährlich.
Dann stand sie plötzlich auf, die
Kleinen wollten anfangen zu saugen.
Und dann waren für zwei Sekunden,
waren diese Momente da.
Für die Arbeit mit den scheuen Tieren
gibt es im Nationalpark von
Manitoba klare Regeln:
Das Fotografieren ist nur in der Gruppe
unter Leitung eines Führers erlaubt.
Und man darf sich den Tieren bis auf
hundert Meter nähern, aber nicht mehr.
Viele Bären tolerieren uns nicht, laufen
weg, da fahren wir auch nicht hinterher.
Also, wir können nur mit den Bären
arbeiten, die uns tolerieren,
das heißt, die sitzen bleiben,
und auch ganz relaxed spielen.
Dadurch haben wir
teilweise die Situation,
dass wir eine Bärin vier bis
fünf Stunden haben.
Norbert Rosing liebt die
analoge Fotografie
und hat viele Bilder noch
auf Film aufgenommen.
Hier prüft er Dias mit Motiven
seiner Reisen nach Kanada und Grönland.
Dann kam halt die Einführung der
Digitalfotografie in den nuller Jahren
und ich hab mich der sehr,
sehr lange verweigert
und bin auch nie ein richtiger
Fan des Ganzen geworden.
Das, was heute mit der
Fotografie gemacht wird,
kann ich zum Großteil
nicht nachvollziehen,
weil es, weil ich hab die
authentische Fotografie geliebt.
Er fotografiert auch gern in
seiner unmittelbaren Nachbarschaft,
am bayerischen Ammersee.
Besonders liebt er die Winterlandschaften.
Ihn interessiert die unberührte Natur.
Mein Thema ist das wilde Deutschland,
so wie es, sagen wir mal, vor hundert, vor
zweihundert Jahren gewesen ist,
davon sind nur noch kleine Inseln da,
aber diese Inseln sind schon wieder bedroht
durch neueste Technologien und so weiter,
und ich versuche, den Menschen zu zeigen:
Leute, so sieht es im Moment aus,
lasst es uns bewahren,
auch für die nächsten zumindest
zwei, drei Generationen.
Rosings Bilder wurden auch in
renommierten Magazinen wie Geo
und National Geographic abgedruckt.
Sogar die Deutsche Post nutzte
seine Motive für Briefmarkenserien.
Regelmäßig besucht er die Eisbären
im Münchner Tierpark Hellabrunn.
Als UN-Botschafter setzt sich
Norbert Rosing
für biologische Vielfalt
und Artenschutz ein.
Häufig fotografiert er hier
den Eisbären Yoghi.
Ich respektiere ihn sehr stark, weil er halt
für den sehr häufigen Nachwuchs sorgt, ne?
Also ich komme ganz gerne in den Zoo,
weil erstens komme ich sehr,
sehr nah an die Bären heran,
und zweitens vergleiche ich sehr gerne, wie
sehen die Bären draußen aus in der Natur
und wie sehen sie im Zoo aus.
Live-Bilder aus der Wurfhöhle mit dem
neuen Eisbärjungen können sich Besucher
schon jetzt im Tierpark ansehen.
Im März wird das Junge dann seinen
ersten Auftritt im Gehege haben.
Für Norbert Rosing aber geht
es bald schon wieder in die Arktis.
Dort will er im ewigen Eis
magische Momente einfangen,
die man so vielleicht nicht
mehr lange sehen wird.